thank you
all right welcome back everyone to the
simon seminar geometric methods and
optimization and sampling so next we'll
have max roginski uivc who will give us
a wonderful tutorial
on
sampling using diffusions so
max all right um
well okay uh thank you very much asia
for the
introduction thank you to the organizers
for uh for inviting me for an
opportunity to
actually present this um
in person because i love coming back
here to the simons institute
um
so my original plan was to give a talk
about london monte carlo but after
andreas masterful exposition
covered everything i would have talked
about
i decided to change things a little bit
and to tell you about a class of
diffusion processes for exact sampling
that has been um
part of my recent interests
and uh the nice thing about this is that
you will see the
connections to stochastic calculus
and pdes
and
there is an indirect connection to
optimal transport as well that i'll
mention towards the end so it ties
together
the topics of um
of this uh
boot camp
i think in a in another in a rather
organic way um
so a couple of kind of
logistical remarks my eyesight is
terrible so if you raise your hand to
ask a question i won't see it
and so it's not like i'm ignoring you
it's like i can't see it so if you want
to ask a question just just
speak up
and also i guess i can't even keep my
eyes on the clock so i'm gonna just
start this thing to buzz at 50 minutes
in okay and then i i guess that that'll
leave time for questions if i'm done
before that
all right so
um
all right let's get into it
so
we've talked about
the launch of our dynamics right so the
idea was
that
you want to sample from
from a distribution
that has
a density f
with respect to the beg measure
on
rd
right um
some additional assumptions under f i
mean typically it's assumed that it's of
the gibbs form so it's e to the minus u
use some potential you impose all sorts
of
um restrictions on a potential but the
idea is that you do this by means of a
diffusion process
right this longivan diffusion process
dxt it's an ethos stochastic
differential equation
and here we have
grad log
fxt
so you're doing gradient descent
basically
on negative log likelihoods
and here you have the standard brownian
motion
so here time
is
starting at zero
and
um
you start with some nice probability law
mu naught
for
for the initial point
zero
and then the idea is that under some
conditions that you impose you want uh
the convergence of
column ut
to the target
asymptotically right as t goes to
infinity and then of course you know you
might want to get rates
for this thing
which is exactly where various
functional inequalities come in
conquering equality is logarithmic
overlapping qualities etc but the moral
of the story here is that
with the launchbound process which is
extremely simple to implement because
here you you only need to know
f
up to multiplicative constant because
any sort of a multiplicative constant is
killed by the gradient
and this and this is a stochastic
differential equation with a time and
variance drift
right uh
instead i want to talk about
a different approach
instead i want to talk about sampling
now
from a target mu
that has a density f
with respect to standard gaussian
on our d right so standard gaussian on
rd
gamma is this
traditional notation it's the usual
thing that we all know about
right this is the
standard
gaussian density
gaussian measurement
and i would like to set up a diffusion
process
uh
dxt for now i'm going to denote the
drift of this by some generic b
this drift now will be time varying
and we have the gaussian noise the
brownian motion
here
we're going to impose two different
restrictions first of all we're going to
require
that our time
starts at zero
and ends in let's say 1 hour you know
your units of time
we started the origin
so deterministic initial condition
and the goal
is to guarantee that
mu your target is exactly
the law of this thing at t equals one
right obviously this is an idealization
because clearly you know the way i've
set this up
you might be thinking about some sort of
free lunch there's no free lunch because
once you have to discretize this thing
all sorts of nasty
uh limitations pop up
um
discretization and monte carlo based on
this
is still a very active research area so
you know there are a lot of a lot of
things to do and i'm sure you know some
of the talks
um in the rest of boot camp and the rest
of this program might actually lead to
some developments in this
but this is our goal so
the problem of
starting with
just a brownian motion
and adding a drift that depends on time
such that you start at the origin
but
then at t equals one you end up with a
sample from a target distribution
this is known
as the schroedinger bridge problem
so
well it's it's a special case of a
schrodinger bridge problem which which
is a bit
more
general than this
uh and it goes back to
a couple of papers by sringer one of the
founders of quantum mechanics where he
was interested in
um certain problems really related to
understanding
quantum effects
uh but also understanding something
about laws of nature and their
stochastic description
the basic formulation of something like
this suppose you have
um a particle
and this particle
diffuses through space
um and your null hypothesis is this is
standard diffusion right so its position
at time t
obeys
the usual
gaussian sort of law right so there's
the brownian motion process
and this is your null hypothesis if your
null hypothesis is true at t equals 1
you should look and you know the
distribution of this particle of
position of the particle should be
standard gaussian so now suppose you
have and such particles they all start
in the corner of some let's say large
cube or something like that you let them
go
you know the usual thing
they diffuse you look at the empirical
distribution of these particles at t
equals one and it does not look gaussian
so what's the minimal most parsimonious
explanation
of this
right so how should we perturb
the gaussian
you know the brownian motion in order to
account for this non-gaussian
distribution at equal one schrodinger
didn't exactly phrase it this way
but uh you know through lots of
subsequent works by you know
mathematical physicists and probabilists
it was crystallized into that particular
form and and then it was realized
that what was really going on
is
a formulation of an optimal transport
problem but in the in the entropic sense
as opposed to
uh monash kanterovich
formulation where you have a metric
so
the abstract formulation so before i
construct
this sde in real time basically using
you know bits and pieces of stochastic
calculus and some pdes
right in front of you
using a derivation that i think is has
at least some original bits
um
i'd like to
first formulate what you might call a
static version of this problem and we'll
see that from that we'll we'll be able
to work our way backwards
to the construction of this drift
which these days is also known as the
filmer drift
named after hans filmer who wrote a lot
of papers related
to this
okay so
so let's set the stage for the static
optimization problem so we're going to
be working on this path space omega
and it's the space of
continuous functions
from the unit interval
into rd
and
we're going to define p
so p
is the winner measure
basically fancy words for the law
of the entire sample path of the
standard brownian motion starting at the
origin at t equals zero but
here we're only talking about its
segment
from t equals zero to t equals one
right so um
we would like to
instead
generate construct another
probability measure on omega
that has the following property so so
the goal is
the following so so let me let me uh
define
the set mu
as the following set it's going to be
all
probability measures
on omega and i'm not going to spend my
time wallowing in
technicalities about how you know what
the sigma algebra here would be etcetera
you know measure theoretic niceties that
you know are easy to
reconstruct but there are two conditions
um
so q naught
which is the law at time zero is the
dirac sitting at zero
and q1
is mu
right so this is the set of all possible
distributions on this path space
that started the origin just like the
standard brownian motion and then you
look at t equals 1 and you get a
distribution mu
and the static formulation of the
schrodinger bridge problem is the
following i would like to
construct a measure
q mu
if it exists
as a minimizer
overall measure
for all measures
in this set
of the relative entropy or the kl
divergence
between q and the weiner measure
right so this is uh
there are no diffusions here yet we're
just talking about basically sampling in
function space
right we have you could you can almost
think about a prior
or some sort of a default measure on the
function space which is the wiener
measure and we know that realizations of
the wiener process are continuous
with probability one you can actually
construct versions that are continuous
everywhere um
and so we'd like to find a measure
with satisfying these conditions
so the same initial distribution as a
standard linear measure but you know the
distribution at t equals one is
manifestly not galaxies
right so this is our problem um
so first
even without formulating anything about
diffusions
you can extract a whole lot of
structural information just by
exploiting the fact that you're
minimizing
the
relative entropy
so
let's fix some uh q
mu
and write down um
this relative entropy
okay
so there's this wonderful result about
relative entropy called the chain rule
and by the chain rule i can um express
this relative entropy as follows so i'm
going to look at what happens at t
equals one
so just the marginals
equals 1
plus
so i'm going to write this down first
and then i'm going to introduce
uh the definitions
so there's going to be an integral over
rd
with respect to
u1
so here x
is
just an element of rd times the
divergence between two measures
which i'm going to be denoting by
qx
dx and what are they
so
qx
is basically the conditional law under q
uh
subject to the condition that
x1
is equal to x
right so so so this is uh now
a probability measure on the spat space
omega
subject to being pinned at location x at
t equals one the same thing goes
for p
so this is defined analogously
and this measure is very well known it's
uh this distribution is called the
brownian bridge being that x
so this is uh
okay so um
and from this we can already extract
something useful
because you see
q1
is mu
p1 is gamma the standard gaussian right
so therefore i can write my relative
entropy
dx is the same thing but you know
obviously the underlying measure is p so
this is the you know weiner measure
conditioned on being at the point x at
time 1.
right
so this is equal now to
relative entropy between d
the relative energy mu and gamma
plus
basically an integral
with respect to
[Music]
mu rather
uh
right with respect to mu
dx
relative entropy between
2x
dx
and divergences are non-negative
so this term is non-negative
and therefore this
is lower bounded by
the divergence between just the terminal
distributions
and of course equality is achieved
if and only if
uh these two measures have the same
bridges
right so almost everywhere
and that basically means that
we know the structure of the minimizing
measure
right so so therefore
this tells us the following remarkable
fact it tells us that
uh
the density the radon nicotine
derivative of the minimizing measure
with respect to the wiener measure
evaluated at so w here is the entire
path
right
from the unit interval into into rd this
looks
like this it looks like
f of w one so f is the density of the
target with respect to the gaussian
measure
therefore we see that if we want to get
a sample from
from mu at t equals one all we need to
do
is take realizations
of the brownian standard in motion and
re-weight them
and the re-weighting is given by this
right so it's almost like an important
sampling type situation
but of course we all know that
re-weighting like this is not pleasant
you actually want to have a generative
mechanism you don't want to operate on
measures you want to operate on
realizations
so this mean means that what would
really would like
is is a i'm going to call it a transport
map quote unquote
key from omega 2 to omega
right such that
basically
um for any function f
on path space
and this is uh with respect to q mu
this is basically the same thing as
taking expectations back this standard
wiener measure
but now
composing f with this transport now
this is not you know when i say
transport it's like i'm literally
transporting a path to another path
in such a way that this holds so this
holds for all smooth functions on on you
know on this path space and again you
can define it rigorously i'm not going
to do it
but the point is that this is really i
mean you know if you look at modern
machine learning the idea here is to do
something like implicit generative
modeling right you you know
you want to have a mechanism that takes
realizations of the brownian motion
which you can think about as your sort
of you know basic randomness
maps them transports them
in such a way that now you get a sample
from your target measure
so
a rich source of such transport maps
on path space is in fact given by
paths of sds
in the box
uh where it says f of w
is that a subscript one one yes because
this f remember this f
um
is a density with respect to gaussian so
f takes
a d dimensional vector as an argument
and w1 so here oh well let's let's
actually so here w really is
a path
right
so this is an element of omega
right so w1 is the terminal point of
that thank you so in other words so in
other words these are measures on path
space
but the density of the target measure of
this uh optimal measure the schrodinger
bridge measure with respect to the
wiener one is given only it only depends
on terminal point and these are known as
generalized brownian bridge processes
so basically you can sort of wave your
hands and say
that if you have a measure like this
that has this rod on nicodem derivative
with respect to gaussian it's quantum
called standard brownian motion
conditioned to have distribution mu at
time one
there's a beautiful paper by fabrice
baduan about these things
for example and he explicitly introduced
the term conditional stochastic
differential equation
okay so what i'm going to do is now
i'm going to construct a map like this
using
essentially
the brownian motion as the driving noise
and stochastic differential equation
which means i'm going to construct a
derivative
um so this is this derivation like i
said i i haven't seen it anywhere
precisely in this form i think some bits
like this part for example with the
chain rule that's everywhere you know
filmer in his lecture notes that sound
fluor definitely had this
but the part that then goes back uh from
from this formulation to the
construction of drift i think is
fairly new
or at least you know but it seems rather
natural to me because it allows you to
introduce all these ideas from
stochastic calculus and begins
without really much you know effort and
so it it it becomes very natural
so let's do this thing right so one more
notation oh sure yes all right just want
to make sure i'm on the same right page
can you say capital f one more time
i don't know if it's here any any uh any
smooth real valued function on the
linear space i mean if you want to be
cute about it like you know you'd have
to talk about money even calculus and
whatnot but
i mean heuristically this is what
happens can you tell me again how you
got what's in the box this yeah
um
so you know that so the two processes
have the same conditionals given given
the terminal point
right and and then you just write down
the factorization of the measure and you
see that the conditionals cancel away
and the only thing that's left is really
the density between the terminal
density of the two terminal
distributions
right i mean basically the idea is that
if i have if i have joint distribution
uh
on two objects x and y and it looks like
this
mu d y
k
x d y
and then q like q looks like this
new d y
k x do i know that the conditional
kernels are exactly the same
the rather nicotine derivative of this
with respect to this is just the rather
nicodemic uh negative derivative of muse
is nothing new
divide them and you you see this
okay so
so what i'm going to do
now is i'm going to construct
an sde that's going to give me this
right so at some point you're gonna have
to use some
amount of foresight
and the amount of foresight i'm going to
use is i'm going to look for
uh
sdes a very specific form
so i'm going to make kind of a gradient
yes
so i'm just a bit
you never use what's in the box to
actually come with your
your desired outcome right because we
could also needed we won this push
forward map way before we actually came
to that conclusion that's right yes yeah
okay so so right so now now we're going
to get to the construction and push
forward so so we're going to make a
gradient on sats
right so
we're going to look for a process that
look that's going to look like this it's
going to be governed by an ito sde
that's going to have a drift
in a form of negative gradients
starting at zero
e runs from zero to one
all right then let
q
is the law of x so the entire path right
remember x here is
denoting the entire path
and what i would uh one not
t and what i would like to guarantee is
that
this thing has um
so i want q to be q mu right so in other
words what i would really want is dq by
dp
evaluated at
you know the generic path
to look like this
that's the goal
but we have this drift so so this so at
this point this is where we pull out
some results from stochastic calculus
so if you look at the standard brownian
motion
and this these two processes differ by
just a drift and there's a fundamental
result in stochastic calculus called the
gersana theorem that basically says
that any two distributions
on the path space that only differ by a
change of drift is absolutely continuous
with respect to each other and you can
actually write down the rotten nicotine
derivative exclusively
so
so the gear sum of theorem
and again there are conditions for it to
be
valid you know such as the novice off
condition or you know the banished
condition but you know
you can look it all up um the drift in
this case would look like this
uh
or rather the um
the rather nicotine derivative
it's going to involve a stochastic
integral
of the drift
against the standard brownian motion so
this is multi-dimensional brownian
motion this is an inner product
and then we're going to have
a term that's going to look like this
this is euclidean normal
right so now what i would like to do
is to choose v show you that you can
construct a v that will
uh basically just
give me this
i want
this to equal
just f w1 that means i have to eliminate
all this stuff that depends on the
entire path
okay so how do you do it
um
basically
the idea is to eliminate first to
eliminate the stochastic integral to to
express it as uh just ordinary
integration of a stochastic process with
respect to time
and as far as i know
this trick
um
is due to vatsav venice and larry shep
in a number of papers and you know
it's really been exploited by by a
number of people since then
um
so what we're going to do is the
following
we're going to define so let v of t
be
this
v function right so this drift is a
gradient of a function
which i'm going to assume is twice
differentiable in x once differentiable
in t
and let v
be a scalar valued process
that takes the standard wiener process
and feeds it into this function
so
why am i doing this
is because now i can use ito's rule
so by ito's rule we know
that
v1
is equal to
v0
um
well let me let me write in
differentiable differential form first
so dvt
is going to be the following thing this
is going to be so so this is the part of
the um
ethos rule that gives you the usual
chain rule
so this is partial of v with respect to
t
then we're going to have
um
this thing so this is going to be the
laplacian of v that's why we need twice
differentiability
and then
third term is going to be
the noise term and that's going to be
the gradient
b
you know and that's going to be you know
driven by by the galaxy noise so ethos
rule gives me this
um and therefore i can integrate it from
from t equals zero to t equals one so if
i integrate i get v one is equal to v
zero
plus an integral from zero to one of
this whole thing so now you see this is
where you know this is where pdes are
going to going to appear so we already
have a function of two a spate of a
space variable and of a time variable
and the laplacian makes an appearance
i'm going to you know write this all out
and it's full gory detail because i'll
need all this stuff
and then i have the stochastic integral
okay so now we stare at this and like i
said this is just a really ingenious
device
where
you see everything in this formula
it's just ordinary
integration except for this little term
but this little term ah this
marker is worthless
except for this little term and this
little term is precisely up to a sine
is a stochastic integral that i would
like to eliminate here
right
so therefore
i can write
so you see that the minus
the stochastic integral
this is the etho integral
against the standard brownian motion
right this is equal to
v0 minus v1
plus
that's one
bad thing about giving a board talk you
can't copy and paste so now i have to
copy this all by hand
right so we have this and now we're
going to substitute that into this
radon nicotine
derivative
so let me do that
i think we all know where this is going
to go
so the idea is
that
you know there are terms in here that
depend only on the terminal time one and
then there's an integral that depends on
the entire path and the idea is to
impose conditions on v that allow me to
set that integral to zero
but all in all i get that dq by dp
is
the following thing so after i eliminate
if i substitute this formula for the
stochastic integral into here i'm just
going to write the end result the end
result looks like this
so this is
v of 0 0
minus v of
w one one
minus
the integral from zero to one of the
following
thing so
here we have the partial of v with
respect to t
here we have half the laplacian
looks like i'm gonna have to move to the
next line but that's okay
minus right because there was a plus
sign
here
minus
half the squared norm of the gradient
of v
right so basically now i have to you see
this is what's going on here this
depends only on w1
this depends on the entire path so
naturally what i would like to do is to
find v
that'll accomplish two things it'll set
this integral to zero
and you know nice way is to just
guarantee that this integrand is always
zero and then the remaining terms will
give me
f of w1
right so
therefore you know this is where you get
the pde
right so let's suppose that our v solves
the following
uh koshi problem
d by dt
v and now is just a function of x and t
plus half the laplacian
is equal to half the square norm of the
gradient
right
so
on the entire space
and the unit interval subject to the
terminal condition v of x comma 1 is
some function
i'm going to write it with
with a bit of foresight as
negative log side of x here psi of x is
some
function that's strictly positive
okay
so i mean there are pde experts in this
audience and i'm sure they recognize
this thing right away
this is
hamilton jacobi bowen equation
it's a pde and it's non-linear because
of the squared normalized gradient
thankfully there's a wonderful trick
going back again to theory pd's known as
the kohlhoff transformation or the
logarithmic transform and in the context
of fdes and control was used by wendell
fleming
so the idea is the following
so let's do log transform
let's define h x of t
as e to the minus v
x t
and then it turns out that this h solves
a much nicer pde a h solves this is an x
like just really character building
exercise and multivariate calculus
right so we still have the laplacian
but the right hand side is zero
on
rd
r1 and the terminal condition now is h
of x1
is
side of x of course we need to choose
the side of x
right so this is actually like if you if
you look at you know your client you
know any good textbook on on pdes you'll
you'll see this but wendell fleming was
the one who really used it in the
context of probabilistic systems and
control to you know really great effects
plus also you know if you've heard of
something called stochastic mechanics
this is ed nelson's attempt to kind of
come up with a stochastic formulation of
quantum mechanics it's there as well
so this pde
this we can actually solve
so this is remarkable that this this
piggy can be solved
using another
very basic result that that ties
together theory of diffusion processes
and
certain class of parabolic pdes
and it's the final cards formula
and this is really a simple version of
final cut formula there's a much more
complicated thing with a multiplicative
potential but you know this is good
enough for our purposes basically the
claim is this
and then this h
of x and t
is equal
to a conditional expectation
of the terminal condition
psi
at time one
given
that the brownian motion at time t
was at point x
right so this is on
right in particular we see that h of 0 0
is simply the expected value with
respect to standard gaussian
of
psi of x
right so
uh i mean we actually i can easily
prove the fine and cot's formula i mean
at least one direction of it that that
is this is the representation and the
idea is once once again to use ethos
rule
so ethos rule gives me the following
so basically it says that
d h
w t t
is equal to
this
this is the generator
of the brownian motion
and the wonderful thing is that
this whole thing
is zero
by the pd that this solves and therefore
we can write
h of w one
comma one
is equal to h of
w t
t
plus
m t and m t is a zero mean marking gail
it's a stochastic integral here
so therefore now all i need to do
is take the conditional expectations of
both sides
conditioning on x t
so therefore o or well w t so
conditioning on this
x not t of course
right so
the martingale has zero mean
and i'm only left with this
and of course we can't see there i'll
step away and of course this thing is
just psi of
w1 so i gave you a very quick proof of
final thoughts formula in its simple
version
right okay so
so therefore
coming back to this we see that this uh
this this has paid off and what we're
left with
is the following
so putting everything together we'll
look with the following
thing so so dq
by
dt of w is
x of 1. so this is
v of 0 0
minus
v of w 1 1 because
the integral that was there and i raised
went away because of this pde
right and so
now we write this as
what we write this as
h
of
w 1 1
divided by
h
0 0 and by construction this is
psi of w 1 that does not look like psi
divided by expected value of
psi
and now you see what what you do you
just take psi
yes
well here i mean this this you know here
you assume that f is nowhere nowhere
zero
right so and now we see that in fact
expectation value
of psi respect to w1 is simply one right
because
right because this is f
and this is simply the fact that uh you
know f is the rather negative derivative
of mu with respect to standard galaxy
and therefore you see that this is
exactly
f w1
so now
that means that the drift that we were
looking for
see it actually does come off
[Music]
uh the drift that we're looking for
has this form
is now
[Music]
yes unconditioned on
wt being x
[Music]
and therefore
our sd looks like this
now it's
a negative gradient of that right so
this is gradient with respect to the
space variable of log
this thing
and
x oh here of course
i should put in
x t
and here the expectations with respect
to the wiener measure xt is non-random
is is
conditioned on that
uh x0 is zero
here runs from zero to one and this
already automatically guarantees
that x1
will have law mu
and this is the optimal process
right and i mean so so a nicer way of
writing this
uh is to introduce the euclidean
euclidean heat semi group
um i'm not gonna do it but there's
there's there's a way to do it but the
point is that this
is
the foamer drift
that you know appears in this problem of
optimally
perturbing the brownian motion
to
give me a desired distribution at t
equals one
in such a way that the resulting
measures on fat space are as close as
possible
in the sense of relative entropy
okay
any questions
yes
sorry could you say again under which
conditions
theorem is valid does this require
gaussianity
uh no um gaussianity of one
oh no okay so here's here's here's
here's the sound of theorem in uh
um
in the following
setting so so the idea is that
so dq by dp so p here is the winner
measure so as long as there exists
a process
that's you know adapted to the
filtration generated by the brownian
motion it looks like this so process u
ut
dwt
plus
no there's no gradient because this is a
general
so as long as this
basically so let's call the z
so as long as this has
expected value one under the um
under the wiener measure
then you can show
that
and now suppose you have a uh you have
uh this
x t so all right
q
is plenty of time zone i can actually
explain this so here we assume that q
is the law of x
the idea is that if i now define the
following process if i define
a process called
w u
that looks like this it's x
t minus x 0
minus this integral of the drift
usds
this
has brown this is a brownian motion on
the q in other words what happens
here x has some distribution q
if i subtract the drift
the resulting object is a brownian
motion so the idea is that you know any
two
probability measures on this linear
space that are absolutely continuous
with respect to another one one another
differ only by a change of drift and you
can actually write down this rather
negative derivative explicitly the
conditions need to guarantee that you
have this
like this is what you as long as you can
prove that this is the case in europe
okay so
uh
this yes
um well the only right so so so i mean
the only basic assumption
um is
this f is let's say um everywhere
positive
and um
i mean you you could usually assume like
you know it's bounded so
and this gradient is bounded right so
the lipschitz so that way you can
guarantee existence of a strong solution
right because i mean
under weaker condition you can you know
you can show this as d has a weak
solution which basically means you can
construct some other probabilities based
on which all this
is going to be true as opposed to saying
x d is basically a functional of the
brownian path at the time t which is the
notion of the strong solution it's
precisely that transport map t
that encapsulates the fact that you know
we're building a
you know strong solution so there has to
be like progressive measurability and
related assumptions
but uh
yeah i mean the assumptions on f are
like i said fairly minimal
yeah yeah just make sure
to that expectation there it's really
just over a singles sorry to the right
no it's conditional right because i mean
this is so so here the idea is that
you're looking at the conditional
distribution of the of the browse
brownian motion of time time one given
time t and those have an explicit form
right i mean it's just gaussian
with so so so the conditional just so
okay well let's actually write this out
so let's define the following thing
uh
kt of some function f
is defined as expected value
of f
x plus
root t
z
where
z
is a standard gaussian
then um
the former drift here so negative so so
then the idea here is that
this v
that we have
v of x d
that drift over here
is
negative log
k 1 minus t
no
b is the wiener measure so
once you're conditioning it as you wrote
it there right
that expectation say that it
it's a multivariate gaussian with a mean
at x t and variance one one minus t
i don't know
if it's just
no no i mean these so so the the
distribution i already wrote it down
this is the conditional distribution i
mean okay you can say it's a
multivariate gaussian whose variance is
one over t times one minus t times
identity
but but the point of the reason why i
wrote it this way is because we obtained
this expression through the transition
functions of transition probability
functions of the standard brownian
motion but once you condition it
once a condition it's really yes i mean
i mean because it's obvious right this
is this you can just explicitly write
this out
in fact this is uh you know like if
you've seen this uh whole what nestor of
spaconi you know randomization approach
yeah okay just make sure yeah
okay in the same questions is this
this is the unique part but is this the
the only way to get if i actually want
to get the solve the drift problem
no it's not no no it's not the only way
i mean like i said i like this way
because it's natural because you go you
have two expressions for the for the
density that you want one of them
[Music]
yes there is a way to see that so the
idea is to consider all possible
uh drifts that just somehow result in mu
at t equals one
and uh and it's basically just the data
processing argument you see right away
that uh the the relative energy so you
know for any drift it's just a relative
entropy between you know the
corresponding path space measure and the
weiner measure once again you use the
chain rule
and you see that you can always decrease
it
by you know having these two having
having you know this candidate measure
in a brownian uh uh you know the linear
measure have the same bridges
same argument using chain rule so with
that again
no but okay so let me introduce
any of the chaos it tells you there's
a measure
oh i mean right if you're not minimizing
the kl there are lots of choices
obviously right
no the minimizer of the kl is unique um
and and now i want to uh
revisit this this non-linear pde that
that
that
that we uh kind of
solved using you know it's kind of
um
i actually have one minute left so you
know there's plenty of time right so so
remember this v i mean one minute left
50 minutes so 10 more minutes after that
so v
remember that you know what what was
happening is this b
had to solve this hamilton jacobi
bellman
it's called hamilton jacobi bowen
because you know like if you're trained
in
uh ddes you'll recognize it but you know
to
do a control theorist
this just
creates all sorts of flags and you know
what to do next so so it looks like this
so hamilton
by dt or dxt
plus half the laplatian
e
is equal to one-half
so
x and t
year one and uh the condition was that
uh v of x
one was negative log
f of x
so
again you know if you see the words
hamilton jacobi palmer like there has to
be an optimal control problem there
somewhere and in fact there is the
optimal control problem
hides in a following way
and this is one of those things where
you see certain
quantities and you just
recognize it this
is the minimum
or all vectors in our d
of this
inner product of u
the gradient v
plus one half
squared norm of u
now
what you're going to do is you're going
to consider
a controlled
e
so um
basically you're going to do something
like this
dx ut u here is
an adapted drift process
so adaptive means that ut is measurable
with respect to the you know the the
segment of the brownian path up to time
t
but this is u t d t
plus d w t
and uh
u
the superscript u is meant to indicate
that in fact
you know the choice of the drift then
determines the path so we start at zero
key runs from zero to one and we define
for each stage drift
the following objective
the j view
is expected value
of one half
the integral from zero to one
of the squared norm of
ut
minus
log
f
okay so what do we see
the idea is that we would like to add a
control
to a standard brownian motion the
control comes in the form of drift and
each control comes with a cost the cost
penalizes the total effort
right this is the you know control
energy throughout the entire path and
then there's a terminal cost that
basically says okay start at zero
choose a drift
and wherever you end up at time time one
we're going to penalize you by minus log
f
so you know so so this is the terminal
cost this is the running cost and now
you see
that this is the hamilton jacobi belmont
for the value function if you know what
that is for this control problem
right so therefore we see
that the former drift is such that
it is the control that minimizes
the sum and moreover you can actually
see that the minimum value of this
overall admissible drifts it also has to
satisfy you know drifts have to be
square integral like this
this is equal to zero
and achieved
by the foamer drift
and from this you see right away
so you see so this uh so so therefore so
let's call this j star
equal to zero because j star is equal to
zero but j star is equal to two things
so by gerson of theorem
the first term is simply the kl
divergence
between
q mu and p
and the second term is actually negative
kl divergence
between mu and gamma
and these two things are equal
and therefore you see that
with the former drift the you know this
is precisely that fact that the the the
density of q mu with respect to p
only depends on the terminal point
therefore it's a generalized brownian
bridge
and you can immediately see
simply by data processing inequality
that for any other u
that gives you mu at t equals one
this scale that this cost is greater
than or equal to zero therefore kl diver
so so okay so
so for any u
such that
xu1
has long u
j of u
is equal to
kl divergence between
this uh q so q is
well q u
log x u
minus this terminal cost is always the
same because we assume that you know we
get mu at times
greater than greater than zero this is
greater than or equal to zero
and therefore any other drift is going
to give you a value that's um
that's that's the gale divergence here
is going to introduce some waste the
former drift is sort of the most
parsimonious it really uses up the drift
in the most economical way meaning that
all the drift goes into making basically
just equalizing these two terms
and obviously these two terms are you
know like this is greater than or equal
to zero simply by data processing but uh
for kl divergence but you also see that
this comes out of the control
formulation
okay so uh
yes
why did you write uh that the square
norm of the gradient was this minimum i
mean did you use it somewhere or i think
yes so so so the idea is the following
um
okay so i can tell you
sorry i mean i i assume too much
so the idea is the following
so
so consider the following controlled as
d e
so same thing control this d is d x u t
is u t d t
plus
d w t and let's suppose you start
x u zero
and zero
let's say t is between 0 and 1.
and what you would like to do is
minimize so j of u now
is going to be the following thing it's
going to be expected value
of some running cost so there's going to
be some some cost function c of
the position of this particle and the
control
and that is give you a terminal cost
let's call this terminal cost
g
of x
u1 and you'd like to find
so
and you'd like to minimize this thing
overall use and it turns out that the
optimal so what happens then you have to
set up
a pd that comes from dynamic prince
dynamic programming principle
so this is just a part of the dynamics
that comes from the fact that if you
don't add a drift you have just a
standard brownian motion
and here you have to have minus minimum
now these u's are vectors
and here you have to have
u
inner product with gradient v x t this
comes from the fact that simply applying
ethos rule for a fixed for fixed uh
vector u consider a sd with a generator
so the generator of that is
this plus that
and here you're going to have the
control cost c
x and u
and if you find such a and then the
terminal condition for this thing dx1
has to be your terminal cost
so then if you find such a function
there's a result called the verification
theorem that basically has that so then
the optimal
control
is of the markup form it only depends on
the current state x
and it's basically a negative gradient
of this
dxt
so so that's why what i did there is you
see i recognized this uh you know and
this is this was like again sort of you
know wendell fleming's uh uh brilliant
insight that this thing just from
legendary french duality is the minimum
of this and once you write it in this
way you see you're minimizing over
controls this becomes an optimal control
problem
that you can solve
right so so
uh
there's a nice book by uh fleming and
ritual on deterministic and stochastic
optimal control it really goes into
detail on this
i mean and this sort of thing like you
stare at some non-linear function and
you recognize it as
an extremum
is a rare skill i mean the only other
instance when there was one
was deployed to just you know dazzling
uh
effect is uh this paper by ramon van
handle on the boreal earhardt game when
um there was a pde that appeared uh in a
work by uh
uh
uh christopher borel and uh on on this
air harding quality fundamental
inequality for gaussian for gaussian
measures
and ramon recognized that this
non certain nonlinear expression is
actually a min max and once you have a
min max instead of a control problem you
have a gain
you know again described by sdes and
then you can
uh
do all sorts of stuff just once you
extract this game you you can prove you
know both lower and upper bounds just
using you know interchanges of minimum
maps so this you know this idea of being
able to recognize
that this term which you know brings a
non-linearity here like one way to
eliminate is to do this this logarithmic
transformation it gives you a linear pde
and you know how to solve it but the
other one is
is recognizing that this is a
minimum of this you know additional
hamiltonian term hamiltonian in the
sense of contract and maximum principle
not you know
necessarily
hamiltonian dynamics anyway um that's
all i have to say so thanks for
listening and uh
and thanks for the great questions i'm
sure there are probably more
all right thank you
thank you thanks for that wonderful
uh exposition so if there are any
questions
i have a question
so what happens to i mean if in the
original optimization problem you saw
the q and the p
so here you fix the b on the second
coordinate of the kl but i mean
you know if you if you swap them
how does this their story go with that
um
i mean that's a very natural formulation
obviously you know i i haven't tried it
but you know i think the technology that
i presented
you could try and see whether it you
know needs anything sensible
um
right so you know once again because you
know the the the two diffusion processes
whose you know path space laws are
absolutely continuous or you know dude
okay let's go this way two fusion
processes are different by change of
drift their laws are mutually absolutely
continuous and you can write a rod on
the negative derivative of you know any
one of them with respect to the other
with an explicit formula and then you
like probably play the same game and
stuff like that
right but but the only thing of course
is that uh
[Music]
it's um it's relatively straightforward
about what to do with you know the
re-weighting of the wiener measure
but once you know you're trying to write
it the other way i mean you have to look
at the actual marginal of your cue
process right and you don't know what
that is ahead of time and then you have
to get
guarantee that you you go the other way
so there there probably is a version of
the schroedinger bridge problem where
the two distributions are reversed in or
in the kla versions but um i mean
honestly i haven't i haven't really
tried uh working that out
i mean in principle yes because there
are numerical methods for for optimal
control i mean they're they're you know
they're whole books written on time
distributization of hjb equations so
basically the idea is that you know one
easiest thing to discretize time and
space and solve a dynamic programming
problem for a markup decision process in
discrete
time uh and then you keep track of the
disputalization error
is different
though right you can use different ones
so some of you there's nothing
if i want to
uh if i care about
is that somehow related to how funny you
have to discretize
[Music]
you know also a different drift would
have you know could have other
advantages would be easier to discretize
um the other the other you know
troubling effect of this is an optimal
control problem in finite time and
optimal control problems unlike gradient
descent which just doesn't think it's
completely myopic write it like i'm
going against the negative gradient
right now optimal control problems have
this kind of you know final cause right
basically the terminal condition
influences what happens early on
in particular the value of the former
drift is at zero you need to know the
mean of the target
right so that's a problem because if you
only know the target distribution of the
constant then
that kind of you know that
advantage goes away
so
that means that you could construct
sub-optimal drifts that you know are
easier to the corresponding is easier to
discretize you could you could then
account for
basically it's almost like a
thermodynamic argument right the control
is doing some work
and former drip does the minimum amount
of work and you could characterize okay
if i'm willing to do extra work on top
of foamer you know i could probably
extract some additional advantages from
this
yes
so uh
with j that you had uh previously right
exactly the place you had this right you
had basically the kinetic energy plus
the entropy who did not maybe for a
minute or two with uh about connections
with the entropy regularized optimal
transport
okay the connection to entropy
regularized optimal transport is
somewhat subtle
because uh that so what i introduced
here is called the schrodinger half
bridge
so the idea is that you start at
um a deterministic initial condition
zero could have been anything else but
you start at zero um
now
suppose you start at a random initial
condition
right so
if you start at a random initial
condition
right so so basically the idea is
you have dx t
again some drift dx dt
dt plus dwt
and suppose
x0 has law mu zero and you want to
design a drift in such a way
that
x1 has long u1
that has a density with respect to a
gaussian
and at the same time you minimize
the kl divergence between the law of x
that's q
and uh
t mu zero and t mu zero is the winner is
the winner uh measure but you know now
the initial distribution the initial
position has distribution mu naught
this requires
uh
setting up a forward backward system
um which is a if you discretize it you
get the synchron iteration which is
basically entropic optimal transport in
discrete time but you can come up with a
continuous time version the idea is
so before i wrote chain rule only
looking at dermal distribution now i'm
going to look at all possible couplings
of mu and mu naught mu 1
and you know just so so i'm going to
write down the joint distribution of x0
and x1 and then condition
the rest of the process on the initial
point and terminal points that's a full
bridge
so once again you see that you know the
optimal distribution should have the
same bridges as the brownian
motion
and now you're looking for basically the
uh minimum kl divergence
between
you know minimum coupling of mu naught
and mu 1 and kl divergence
so
that's the relation to entropic
philanthropic optimal transport there's
another wonderful result that you can
put an epsilon in front of the brownian
motion
and and consider these problems now of
course you're comparing everything to
like
uh
a gaussian with you know rescale
variance and then in a certain way if
you scale things just right as epsilon
goes to zero you recover the you know
the optimal monochromatory chl two
what's your stand problem
that's a result by uh tercio mikami so
so this idea that is that in a certain
low noise limit and tropic optimum
transport becomes just ordinary monster
controversial transport this is slightly
different here the idea is that the
transport map quote-unquote it's not
it's optimal in in a different sense the
idea is that you take your wiener
measure your brownian motion basic
brownian motion is kind of this free
resource and you
apply a function to it
that maps paths to paths and you can
think about as kind of a generator in
you know these uh you know implicit
generative models
and the idea is that you minimize the kl
divergence
you perturb the your random resource as
little as possible but this is not the
same thing as an optimal transport
because clearly you're coupling the
direct sitting at zero to like to mu
but this but this is not really like
you're not minimizing cost other than
like this this scale divergence between
the two path space measures
so the full shorting your bridge problem
that does give you entropic optimum
transport and like i said in a low noise
limit gives you
just the usual l2 watch this time and
you can actually recover so you know
from that point you can write down the
the optimal control formulation take
this you know noise variance this year
you end up with the you know
venomous brain formulation for for the
optimum transport
yeah sure
oh um yeah could you give some like
intuition on the flavor of
a sampling problem where this sort of
like possible control style dispersation
is uh it's more favorable in terms of
like
like algorithms um
so
right uh the motivations i know that
make sense to me i mean
in in the context of machine learning i
guess or optimization this is relatively
new
the earlier
problems came from
physicists
who wanted to look at things like
individual biomolecules like rna dna
proteins blah blah blah and you know
these things are swimming in you know in
in solution in a cell
in the presence of brownian motion and
the idea was you want to construct these
nano machines that somehow induce
various distributions in finite time as
opposed to waiting for this thing to
equilibrate
so so physicists actually implemented
some of these things in the lab
uh obviously you know
probably not the same complexity
problems as like neural net or anything
like that but you know the idea was to
induce
an exact distribution
at a finite time
as opposed to waiting you know
for this thing to relax sufficiently
closely to the desired distribution
and uh and then of course you know and
then one can
as i said fall back on fairly extensive
uh
literature on um numerical methods for
optimal control problems to uh to
construct approximate algorithms but of
course you know what's left to do for
sort of our communities is to
come up with fine quantitative bounds on
all of this because you know there
aren't that inferior there aren't very
many
sorry i guess more specifically my
question was like oh thanks for the
answer uh like what about the structure
of the problem
makes
one uh would one be led to believe that
this sort of this sort of iteration um
has faster convergence than like waiting
for like some
uh
well i mean i have i can cook up f in
such a way that it's log several like
its relaxation time is much larger than
one right
so you'd have to wait much longer than
you know one one time unit
oh yeah oh well again discrimination is
is wide open territory
like uh you know it's um
because you know if you discretize uh
just the usual engine dynamics you have
to worry about you know
you may be metropolizing it to get
unbiased
densities and all sorts of stuff like
that so you know once you take all of
that stuff into account
uh you know it becomes kind of
complicated
so i mean you have to make sure you're
comparing oranges to oranges in a sense
right
yeah very little is known about uh you
know the mirrors of uh short anchor
bridges
you're sure the answer is
all right so if the low noise limit to
this is the it gives you the effect that
you're going to bring it why can't you
use that
and that seems like
there's there would have to be some
questions
going on if you just said oh you know we
can sample from the terminal measure by
just having oracle to give you the awful
it works the same way as the the
venomous grenade system works right and
like you you actually have to find the
optimal transport map i have to solve
the login pair equation all this other
stuff
it's not like there's free lunch you
know you know
yes
uh like i said the motivation here is
really you know kind of the physics of a
problem and relative entropy actually
has phys you know physical meaning like
i said in this uh
theory of uh you know nano systems uh
you know you connect this to actually
physical thermodynamic energy
and that's the resource that you know
you would like to
uh you'd like to dissipate as little
heat as possible in into the environment
you know
and plus you know of course we know from
the work of you know marketery and
others that you know somehow just
computationally finding uh you know
transport plans for uh for for entropy
is easier than uh
than a launch problem
all right thanks
thank you